[Music]
good day welcome again to another
episode of Whata Prof I'm Martin Smith
I'm Walter hello Walter hi today we're
going to talk about a little bit what is
the culmination of the End of the Age
correct because people are asking uh
they want to know the
sequence and the world out there has so
many views on the coming of Christ so
just for clarification because we are
dealing with end time issues let's just
give the sequence how it'll take place
right through to the end and uh this
serves basically as as a Bible expose
for those who need a little bit more
info on this issue and like you've said
in the previous ones this is maybe
another tool that you can put in your
toolbox when you want to evangelize
correct so let's open with a word of
prayer our heavenly father thank you
again for bringing us together Lord we
are looking forward to the day when
Jesus comes through the clouds come and
fetch us let us now Enlighten the
viewers and also ourselves on these
subjects in Jesus name amen
amen well Martin everybody's waiting for
history's coming climax I certainly yes
am looking forward to
it this is Wesley's famous declaration I
want to know one thing the way to heaven
how to land safe on that happy Shore God
himself has condescended to teach the
way for this very end he came from
Heaven he has written it down in a book
oh give me that book at any price give
me the book of God then he says I have
it here is knowledge enough for me let
me be homo Unos lib man of one
book so basically what he is saying and
this is what the Reformation said if you
have the
Bible then precept upon precept line
upon line you shouldn't be able to be
rattled because God has put it in the
book and we need to see what it says
acts 1:1 oh ye men of
Galilee why stand ye gazing up into
heaven this same Jesus which is taken up
from you into heaven shall so come in
like manner as ye have seen him go into
heaven that is the death null of
spiritualism true isn't it definitely
yeah because they make it a spiritual
event spiritualize away the literal
coming of Christ and that's why they as
blavatsky said love the cabalistic
versions of the Bible the new ones which
talk of an end of the age and not the
end of the
world and the coming of Christ to them
is not a literal appearing in the clouds
but here we have a very clear statement
that it is a literal event right
so we have to ask ourselves a few
questions why will he come again how
will he come again so that we don't get
confused yes very important because
Jesus warned us there will be false
christs and Satan will impersonate him
correct so why will he come again Titus
2:13 looking for that blessed hope and
the Glorious appearing of the great God
and our savior Jesus Christ now the
grammar in the original Greek here makes
it quite obvious that the great God and
the Savior Jesus Christ are one and the
same so this is a this is another key
verse that tells us about Jesus yeah and
uh it's the Blessed hope that's what
everybody is waiting for I I am stunned
that people don't want it to happen yeah
they're clinging to whatever Earthly
treasure they have treasure yeah yeah
and they obviously are not too
interested in the Blessed hope
right John 14 is my miniature Bible of
the end time these few verses let not
your hearts be troubled you believe in
God believe also in me and my father's
house saw many mansions if it were not
so I would have told old you I go to
prepare a place for you and if I go and
prepare a place for you I will come
again and receive you unto myself that
where I am there ye may be also Martin
is that literal yes you believe it I do
and it's what's wrong with
you I love that those verses that's I'm
so glad this is the King James version
of course in my father's house are many
mansions if you read the modern
translations there are many houses and
if you read the modern modern ones
there's plenty of room you don't get
anything you're a ghost on cloud n so
again they want to spiritualize
everything away and according to this
verse Martin when do you go to heaven
when he comes to receive you when he
comes back to but what does the world
believe you're going to be raptured up
and the other ones believe that when you
die you directly go to him so they're
all there already so what's the point in
coming to fetch them if they're all
there already you know this is it's so
plain and
logical when you let the Bible interpret
itself like I mentioned in my testimony
this is the exact ver verse the last one
that just I mean when you read that and
Discover it through the help of the Holy
Spirit it has to wipe out all those
confusion that read your Bible as it
stands how will it come again
well it will be universally visible
behold he comes with the clouds and
every eye shall see him Revelation 1
verse 7 so every eye will see him Martin
that's
interesting H for as the lightning comes
out of the East and shineth even to the
West so also shall the coming of the son
of man be so it will be a spectacular
event and every eye will see it exctly
that's every eye that's alive will see
it it's not some secret thing that
happens
somewhere now what does it mean when it
says he comes with the clouds well
Hebrew parallelism must answer this for
us Psalms 104:3 who makes the clouds his
Chariot who walketh upon the wings of
the wind so we still don't know what it
is but we have a synonym which they use
cloud
Chariot we go on Matthew 24 and they
shall see the son of man coming with in
the Clouds Of Heaven with power and
great Glory now in your prayer Martin
you said he's coming through the
clouds but he's coming in the clouds yes
yes and then we want to know what these
chariots are Psalm 68:1 17 the Chariots
of God are 20,000 even thousands of Ang
Angels the Lord is among them as in
Sinai in the Holy place so now we have a
clear picture the Bible again interprets
itself so he comes with his thousands
and thousands and millions and millions
of angels that'll be
spectacular if one
Angel walking towards the grave caused
the
earthquake right yeah if one Angel made
them fall like dead men if one Angel
rolled back that stone with his
finger what it going to be like when
billions of angels come one Angel took
out
180,000 Assyrian soldiers in one single
night right no I think it it's
unfathomable yes and the they tried to
tell us it was a rat
plague second Thessalon s 1:7 when the
Lord Jesus shall be revealed in heaven
with his mighty Angels Luke 9:26 when he
shall come in his own glory and in his
father's and of the Holy Angels that's
spectacular right the glory of God is so
that it outshines the
sun numerous times no human eye can
behold it and live unless you
specifically prepared for
it even Moses he just reflected a little
bit of the glory and and the Israelites
couldn't look upon him
yeah Matthew 25:31 when the son of man
shall come in his glory and all the
angels with him then shall he sit on the
throne of his glory so he doesn't come
as the lowly
savior the sacrificial savior he comes
as the king of kings and Lord of lords
so I think it's pretty clear how will he
come spectacularly
exactly Revelations 511 tells us and the
number of them was 10,000 time 10,000
and thousands of thousands now the Bible
doesn't use the word million or billion
or
trillion but if you multiply this out
this is billions and billions of
angels spectacular spectacular yeah
another feature about the second coming
is it will be
audible 1 Thessalonians 4:16 for the
Lord himself shall descend from the
heaven with a shout with the voice of
the Archangel and with the Trump of God
so everybody will hear it yes M that
voice even penetrates the ears of the
dead yes it brings him out of the
grave and he shall say send his angels
with a great sound of a trumpet and they
shall gather together his elect from the
Four Winds from one end of the heaven to
the other so Martin who's going to be
gathered he elect not the others right
you have to be very careful when you
read the Bible what does it really say
yeah not do what does somebody think it
says and what do you want to what do you
want it to say correct so we're not
interested in Dynamic equivalence we
want to know what did God say
right and then a very important verse he
will not touch the
earth and the dead in Christ shall rise
first then we which are alive and remain
shall be caught up together with them in
the clouds to meet the Lord in the
air and so shall we ever be with the
Lord number of points here mhm uh
he sends his angels to gather them and
they come together in the
clouds so they're going to this vast
throng of angels right they'll be taken
up with that vast throng of angels they
meet the Lord in the air and from then
onwards there's no separation anymore
between the redeemed and God right yeah
so this is what will happen when Jesus
returns so if you've read these verses
now what does that do to any secret
leaon there cannot be anything secret
about it no so that's why Jesus warned
if you're heh they're in the Inner Room
don't go if you hear this that and the
other don't
go that's why Jesus warned in Matthew
24:26 and 27 wherefore if they shall say
unto you behold he is in the desert
don't
go behold is in the secret Chambers
believe it not for as the lightning
comes out of the East and shinest even
unto the West so shall also the coming
of the son of man
be uh I told that story once when I was
giving lectures in
Switzerland and uh I was in this big
Hall in
sir and I was lecturing on the New Age
movement and the
mraa I've told this before
somewhere and while I was lecturing
there was quite a large
audience and the people got fed up with
me because they said that's a lot of
nonsense there's no such thing as a mraa
trying to masquerade as Christ at that
stage Benjamin creem was busy with all
of his his being
overshadowed and some of them actually
got got up and they were quite
vociferous they said nah we don't want
to listen to this nonsense and they
walked out and a lot of people walked
out of the hall it's uh quite
disconcerting when that happens Martin
yeah so I said okay Lord they obviously
don't believe this please help a little
bit here and I carried on with the
lecture and the rest of the people
stayed there and I said well I can't
help it if they don't believe it but
this is what is happening and about 20
minutes
later there was a big hustle and they
all came running back into the
Hall isn't that
strange I can think the surprise in your
face yes and I said what's going on now
now it just so happened do you believe
in chance or do you believe in
Providence Mar Providence you believe in
Providence it just so happened that in a
uh
venue in a big hotel just opposite where
we were having the lectures Benjamin
cream was being overshadowed by the mraa
at that exact time while I was
delivering that exact lecture isn't that
amazing and as these people came out a
throng came out of that hotel shouting
and screaming their heads off mraa is
here matre is here and they were handing
out things to the people in the street
and people were saying what's going on
what's going on then they were excited
and said how he'd been overshadowed by
the
mraa and they realized well maybe that
guy's not talking nonsense and they ran
back into the Hall so don't listen if
you hear he's in a hotel in don't go no
no because that's not the way it's going
to come and we've also shown slides
don't believe it when a top Sanhedrin
Rabbi says he's in communication with
he's already talking to him we've shown
the all of those slides we don't have to
do it all right so what will take place
at the second coming that's the next
logical question isn't
it well the Bible tells us it's going to
be the resurrection of the
righteous 1 Thessalonians 4:16 for the
Lord himself shall descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of the
Archangel with the Trump of God and the
dead in Christ shall rise
first does that imply that there's
another resurrection that of the Dead
that are not in Christ yes so there's a
first resurrection and there's a second
Resurrection we have to look at that
right the Bible is
self-explanatory so how long will the
others remain dead it's the next
question right Revelation
20:5 but the rest of the Dead lived not
again until the thousand years were
finished and then it refers to that
previous statement this is the first
resurrection when it describes the
coming of Christ the first resurrection
is the resurrection of the righteous
Thessalonians makes that quite clear and
the rest of the Dead don't wake up for
another thousand years now people will
say you know you're jumping from
Thessalonians to Revelation and maybe to
a verse in the Old Testament but that's
exactly what the Bible says yeah you
have to make a detailed study put all
the verses together here a little there
a little until the picture becomes clear
it may not be
hazy that's so true because then you
won't have a problem of misinterpreting
correct so let's just make absolutely
sure what Resurrection if you should die
before the Lord
comes what Resurrection would you want
to be part of the first one correct
Revelation
20:6 blessed and holy is he that has
part in the first resurrection by
implication it's a very sad thing to be
part of the second
Resurrection so the Bible has two
resurrections the resurrection of life
and the resurrection of damnation that's
pretty clear
right all right at the the second coming
of the the righteous living will be
translated because there will be living
people in a moment in a twinkling of an
eye at the last Trump now we just heard
that Christ will come with the Trump of
God right yes for the trumpet shall
sound and the dead shall be raised
Incorruptible and we shall be
changed so this we refers to the living
yes for this corruptible must put on
incorruption and this Mortal must put on
immortality that's Hebrew
parallelism they just repeating the same
thought in different words yes in other
words you're emphasizing it you're
giving it
power I love the way they wrote that
yeah no it's like you said and even with
the gasms yes it gets lost in the new
translations yes it's totally lost you
need the sandwich you need to see what
is being highlighted yeah it's like
taking a highlighter right except that
God took the highlighter that's
beautifully I got something hidden here
for you I want you to see it so let's
look at a summary in 1 Corinthians 15:
20 22 and
23 but now is Christ risen from the dead
and becomes the first fruits of them
that slept it's interesting that they
slept right yes for as in ad Adam all
die even so in Christ shall all be made
alive Christ the first fruits afterwards
they that are christs at his
coming now this is a interesting verse
because there have been resurrections
before m MH Moses was resurrected yes
because we read that Michael was in a
confrontation yes with the devil right
over his
body and he went to heaven so he he saw
death and he was
raised but he was not the first fruits
he was as it were a postat Check Yes
Christ is the first fruit so he had a
resurrection by promise of the
resurrection of Christ yeah if Christ
didn't rise Moses couldn't have had to
have come back correct so Moses was a
representative of those that were asleep
that would be raised from the dead and
Elijah was a representative of those
that would not see death yes that's why
those two they represent the law and the
prophets yeah came and were with Jesus
on the Mount of transfiguration
it's important to know that Christ is
the first fruit but the Bible does say
in
Romans that death reigned from Adam to
Moses wow yes I remember so it does tell
us that's when for the first time
somebody was resurrected and given
immortality yes death reigned from Adam
to Moses well so this is an interesting
summary but for the rest of
humanity well there are still some
others as well Enoch was an example of
the pre flood World mhm that God would
honor his promise so he was the
guarantee to the pre flood World Moses
and Elijah to the postf flood world
typifying the resurrection at the end
and then there were a couple that were
raised at the resurrection of
Christ yes and
those were went up with his Ascension
into heaven correct because he says when
he went up he took captives in his train
yes and they were forming part of this
first fruits yes that they had to what
their mission is in heaven the Bible
doesn't tell us so let's not speculate
about
it so this brings us to a very important
Point namely the doctrine of the
immortality of the Soul which is a very
intricate portion of the whole sequence
of events it will also play a very big
part in misleading in the end time
correct Genesis 2:1 17 but of the tree
of the knowledge of Good and Evil Thou
shalt not eat of it for in the day that
thou eatest thereof Thou shalt surely
die that was God's
Proclamation 3 verse4 the serpent said
unto the woman ye shall not surely die
we've dealt with this in many cases but
this is what Humanity basically believes
immortality yeah an altered state but
Immortal so even if
you're dead but you're alive you're
Immortal yes so they like to say the
soul will go to heaven but unfortunately
for them Ezekiel
18:20 says the soul that sinth it shall
die because the soul refers to the
entire
entity the soul is the breath plus the
the material the Earth come together and
Man became a living soul that whole
entity will die so there is no ghostly
afterlife 1 Timothy 1:17 now unto the
king Eternal Immortal invisible the only
wise God be honor and Glory forever and
ever amen in other words the only one
who is Immortal is God yes and Only God
can give
immortality 1 Timothy
6:14 that thou keep his commandment
without spot unrebuked until the
appearing of the Lord Jesus Christ
that's the
commission so do and so hear as those
that live according to the law
right verse 15 which in his times he
shall show who is the blessed and only
potentate the king of kings and Lord of
lords who only has immortality that
makes it quite clear so the doctrine of
immortality is not biblical it's a Roman
Catholic Doctrine and it's a pagan
Doctrine dwelling in the light which no
man can approach unto whom no man has
seen nor can see to whom be honor and
power Everlasting
amen and 1 Timothy 6:16
is he in the new King James version says
who alone has immortality dwelling in
unapproachable light whom no man has
seen or can see to whom be honor and
everlasting power now let's just qualify
this nobody can see him if he is
sinful and live will be destroyed by the
brightness of his coming so obviously if
you want to live in the presence of God
you have to have a Immortal
body so Moses had to be resurrected in
an immortal body one that could stand in
the presence of God previously when Mo
Moses was with God God had to Veil his
glory in a cloud when he asked to see
his glory god said you cannot see me and
live but I will hide you in the Cliff of
The Rock and cover you with my hand and
when I go by you can see me from the
back yeah not even from the front no so
this is amazing so no man can live with
in a sinful human State and be in the
presence of God so what does this tell
us what will happen to those unrepentant
ones at the end of time they will be
destroyed they will be destroyed and not
of God's
doing by clinging to their sin by
clinging to sin you will be destroyed
with your sin that's why the Bible says
the man of sin will be destroyed by the
brightness of his
coming so let's just make sure we've had
this many times but uh for clarity's
sake the catechism of the Catholic
Church teaches that man is Immortal the
church teaches that every spiritual soul
is immortal it does not perish when it
separates from the body at death that is
Greek philosophy it's not a
Biblical uh story do they know it yes
the new Catholic encyclopedia tells us
that the soul in the Old Testament means
not a part of man in other words he
cannot separate they know it they know
it but the whole man is a living being
they are so arrogant that in the face of
this knowledge they still claim to
believe the serpent rather than God
yeah so even in the New Testament it
signifies human life the life of an
individual conscious object so the Bible
doesn't teach it they say they teach
it and then it talks if you want to
analyze it so if you want to do an
exeresis on
it it says that the New Testament does
not teach the immortality of the soul in
the hen istic sense of survival of an
immortal principle after death they know
it Martin unbelievable H it's it's a
tragedy if you know you're teaching
something that's not biblical you're
actually teaching the Serpent's language
lie so let's have a quick brief look at
this issue of death the Mystic realm of
death Genesis 2:7 and the Lord God
formed man of the Dust of the ground and
breathed into his his nostrils the
breath of life and Man became a living
Soul he didn't receive
one he is the living entity that's why
when the the breath leaves when your
metabolism stops mhm you go back to dust
yeah so dust
plus breath is a living Soul that's the
definition in the Bible
Daniel
12:13 but go thy way till the end be
thou shalt rest and stand in thy lot at
the end of the days so what is he going
to do he's going to sleep and then he's
going to rise the new King James puts it
this way but you go your way till the
end for you shall rest and will arise to
your inheritance at the end of the days
so just makes it a little clearer that
you do not go to heaven when you die you
rest and you receive
immortality at the
end if we look at John 11 from verse 11
these things said he and after that he
said unto them our friend Lazarus
sleepeth because they thought he was
literally sleeping yes when he said this
yes because Jesus says he sleeps and I
go that I may wake him up then said his
disciples Lord if he's asleep he shall
do well however Jesus spoke of his death
but they thought that he had spoken of
taking of rest in sleep then Jesus said
unto them plainly Lazarus is dead so
when Christ talks about his people when
they die he talks to them as sleeping
yeah not really dead they're sleeping in
him they are alive but they're not
physically
there job makes it quite clear in
chapter 14:10 but man dieth and he
wasteth away yeah man giveth up the
ghost the ruach the breath mhm and where
is
he so
this die give up the ghost means to die
to perish to EXP fire to be about to
die now how long will they
be
gone till the heavens be no more they
shall not awake nor be raised out of
their sleep job
14:2 now the Bible says when Christ
Returns the heavens will roll up like a
scroll yes so when is this this is with
the second coming a little bit here and
a little bit there it's very clear in
job it's very clear yes Ecclesiastes 3:1
19 for that which befalleth the sons of
men befalleth the beasts even one thing
befalleth them as the one dieth so dieth
the other yay they have all one breath
so that a man has no preeminence above a
beast like an animal dies so man dies an
animal has
metabolism and when that metabolism
stops the animal is dead yeah same thing
happens to a human being so it's pretty
clear now the Roman Catholic Church is
adamant that it prefers the Serpent's
version obviously because they called
the man of sin yeah and they want to
cling to sin which is transgression of
the law and they want their cake and eat
it they want immortality so just
redefine what God Said right yeah so po
Leo on Monday December
19513 issued the ball declaring we do
condemn and reprobate all who assert
that the intelligent soul is
mortal and the reason why did that is
because the reformers Martin Luther
amongst them believed that when you die
you sleep yeah so the bull was directed
against this growing what they called
heresy of those who who denied the
natural immortality of the soul and
avowed the conditional immortality of
man so man is Immortal on condition of
obedience yeah so they were totally
against it and you were a heretic if you
believe this correct and Martin Luther
he made the following statement we
should learn to view our death in the
right light so that we need not become
alarmed on account of it as unbelief
does because in Christ it is indeed not
death but a fine sweet and brief sleep
which brings us release from this veil
of tears from sin and from fear and
extremity of the real death and from all
the misfortunes of this life and we
shall be secure and without care rest
sweetly and gently for a brief moment as
on a sofa until the time when he shall
awaken us together with all his dear
children to the eternal glory and joy so
what Martin Luther believed is it in
harmony with the Bible yes and it sounds
actually quite sweet yes it's it's
something not to be U discouraged with
so Martin what about all these stories
about appearances of ghosts and people
talking to that's where the Deception
comes in correct and that's a very very
scary thing now if the dead know nothing
mhm then who's talking to you when that
happens it must be something
spiritual and uh is it an entity from
God no did God forbid communication with
the so-called dead yes why because he
knew that it will take them down a a
path of uh sin and predition correct so
when you're speaking to an entity you're
actually speaking to a
demon I don't know you you look like a
good chap I don't think you ever Dabble
in spiritism like I did right you didn't
use Ouija boards and things like that no
but I hear it's very popular still for a
Christmas gift yes so it's there's lots
of people that still that communicate
with the dead they're talking to Demons
now when my mother was dead I tried to
contact my
mother and I actually spoke to demon
entities and we used the Ouija board as
well
and my wife and I were doing it once and
talking to these
entities we were atheists but we were
talking to enti entities isn't that
interesting yeah it's such a oxymoron
contradiction in
terms and she and I we had our finger on
that glass and it was spelling
out and I asked about my
mother and it spelled out all kinds of
silly
things and uh I was adamant I wanted to
speak to her and then suddenly that
glass went
berserk and It sped across that thing
there was no way you could hold it
up now when that happened the hairs on
the back of your neck they just started
rising and that glass went
crazy and it spelled out go to hell yeah
and when it had finished spelling go to
hell
the glass flew off the table from under
our fingers across the
room now Martin that's when you know
you're not dealing with normal things
you're dealing with the
supernatural so you're speaking to demon
entities and when uh King Saul spoke to
the witch of
Ender there was a veil in between so he
didn't speak directly to this entity but
that entity was a demon
masquerading as
yes so Martin Luther continues and he
says for since we call it a sleep we
know that we shall not remain in it but
be again awakened and live and that the
time during which we sleep shall seem no
longer than if we had just fallen
asleep hence we shall sender ourselves
that we were surprised or alarmed that
such as asleep in the hour of death and
suddenly come alive out of the grave and
from decomposition and entirely well
freshh with pure clear glorified life
meet the Lord and Savior Jesus Christ in
the clouds Martin did he understand it
yes he understood what the Bible is
actually teaching on it scripture
everywhere afford such consolation which
speaks of the death of the Saints as if
they fell asleep and were gathered to
their fathers that is had overcome death
through his faith and comfort in Christ
and awaited the resurrection
together with the Saints who preceded
them in death this is an absolute
biblical exposition of what the Bible
says yes and Satan will definitely use
the opposite to deceive now how
important is it that you know this I
think it will be a life and death
situation so here at the end of time
when loved ones suddenly start appearing
to people yeah uh I mean I I listened to
sanes in my my terrible
days where entities would
speak and they would be in such high
positions in heaven that they would even
supersede the position of Christ I'm
talking about seances with cesil John
roads appearing and even
statements that Adolf Hitler was in a
better position than Christ in the
hierarchy such Blas for
me and then there will be false christs
appearing if you know these
things you will not be confused you know
that Christ will come and he'll stay in
the air that no entity can talk to you
Lite Studios did a great interview with
someone that was um taking part in these
things so I'll put that link in
excellent but then there's also an
interesting thing and I remember you
mentioned it quite a while back when we
were doing the one on
UFOs that's also linking on with this
yes absolutely so and even little I
Studios had a a very good documentary on
that so I'll put that link also in but
this will all form part of this end time
scenario we must watch out for these
deceptions at the end of time this issue
with being appearing in space
vehicles uh and the manifestations that
take place when they appear are very
much the same as you find in some
Pentecostal churches exactly they start
speaking in tongues they start falling
over all of these issues and it is it is
a state of
hypnosis and these are Spirit entities
impersonating other beings so if you
know these things you will not be
deceived now Martin Martin Luther wasn't
the only one who understood it the other
translator of the Bible William Tindle
he understood it as
well he wrote uh here's an article came
he came to the defense of the revived
teaching of the conditional immortality
so early on when the Reformation started
God impressed this truth upon the
reformers and it is
Unthinkable that the very next number of
them would reject it again and go back
to the old that's not in their catechism
well that just shows you how strong of a
delusion this is
correct so they re this teaching was
revived that immortality is conditional
this is as well as other teachings
brought him in direct conflict with with
the papal Champion Thomas Moore who
strongly objected against tendle and
Luther who in the words of Mo said All
Souls lie and sleep till doomsday in
1530 Tinsdale responded
vigorously so MOA was being sarcastic
and say you people say the souls sleep
till doomsday no they don't they go to
heaven they're Immortal right or they go
to hell or they go to Purgatory or
whatever
and uh tendle quite sarcastically
answered and ye talking to Thomas mo in
putting them The Departed souls in
heaven hell and Purgatory destroy the
arguments where with Christ and Paul
prove the
resurrection and again if the souls be
in heaven tell me why they be not in As
Good case as the Angels be and then what
causes there of the Resurrection it's a
good question if they're all happy and
like the Angels why do need to be
resurrected waste of time right
yep so he pressed his contention even
further showing that the papal teaching
on the subject is in conflict with St
Paul nay Paul now he being
sarcastic Thou Art
unlearned go to master MOA and learn a
new way we be not most miserable though
we rise not again for our souls go to
heaven as soon as we be dead and are
there in great joy as Christ that is
risen again and I Marvel that Paul had
not comforted the Thessalonians with
that Doctrine if he had whed it if he
had known about
it that the souls of their dead should
rise again if the souls be in heaven in
as great Glory as the Angels after your
Doctrine then show me what cause should
there be of the
Resurrection so they understood it
Martin and and uh if you go to the
Catholic religion then you'll see that
the Council of Trent decided in
purgatory the souls can themselves wipe
out their debt only by
suffering so there's no salvation by
faith no imputed and imparted
righteousness of Christ you have to be
saved by your works even in
death so Martin when you look at this
little carard and it says is Rust in
Peace then that's really what it's doing
it's rusting in peace but it won't have
a resurrection no but those that rest in
peace they will yeah so when that
Resurrection takes place
Martin that'll be a very joyous day but
uh you will have to be judged before
that right yes so when Christ comes and
he raises you from the dead then he must
have judged you already that is the
investigative judgment correct must take
place in heaven it's biblical yes a lot
of people say no it's not biblical
because it but if he brings his reward
and the verdict worth then obviously it
already had to take place it is so
logical that people don't see it is
unbelievable and he will render to each
one according to his deeds right that
means there must have been a
judgment Romans 2:7 and to them who by
patience continuance in doing well seek
for Glory and Honor and immortality and
eternal life there's something that you
must do to attain
it behold I show you a mystery 1
Corinthians 15 that's a very interesting
sequence in 1 Corinthians 15 from verse
51 I show you a mystery we shall not all
sleep but we shall all be
changed in other words there will be a
resurrection and the living will be
changed at the same time
yes in a moment in the twinkling of an
eye at the last Trump for the trumpet
shall sound and the dead shall be raised
Incorruptible and we shall be changed so
Martin if you only get immortality at
the
resurrection then nobody other than
those few that have been uh
typologically exalted in that
way uh will actually receive it
right for this corruption must put on
incorruption and this Mortal must put on
immortality so when this
corruptible shall have put on
incorruption and this Mortal shall have
put on immortality then shall be brought
to pass the saying that is written death
is swallowed up in Victory oh death
where is thy sting oh grave where is thy
Victory it is crystal clear it is so
clear and nobody in the churches out
there preaches it yes they take the last
verse vers 55 and read that and then put
the person in heaven where if they just
read the previous verses and leave them
out it can't happen because it's only at
this Resurrection when this happens
correct so again let's make sure 2
Timothy 4:7 and8 I fought a good fight I
have finished my course I have kept the
faith henceforth there is laid up for me
a crown of righteousness which the Lord
the righteous judge shall give me at
that day and not to me only but unto all
them also that love is appearing so at
that day is that his death or is that
the second coming Second Coming
qualifies it it is Crystal Clear in the
scripture and you know it's such a Rel
when my father died I had a very strange
experience MH I was alone at his
hospital bed the night that he died and
uh his breath just became shallower and
shallower and shallower and then
eventually he died he stopped breathing
and Martin when he stopped
breathing he suddenly sat up in bed with
his arms stretched out as if he was
greeting
[Music]
someone and I had a very strange
feeling well I drove home from that
hospital that night and I was aware that
there was an entity with me in the car
it was a very strange
occurrence remember I was steeped in
spiritualism and I got
home and I went and sat in in the chair
in the lounge and the doors were closed
and suddenly the curtain
opened now that's very freaky when that
happens but in my in my ignorance I
basically said
goodbye to this entity being convinced
in myself that it was the spirit of my
father right now who produced those
manifestations for my
education Satan and is he doing that
throughout the world yes and is he using
movies to propagate all the time this is
his Trump God yes card MH and that is
why we need to be rooted in the
scriptures to understand what this is
all about that is so important because
like you said this is the trump card
this is the one he's going to use
because this
affects your your emotions
completely when it comes to deceased and
and you have this longing to be in
communication with them right that's why
I wanted to speak to my mother I mean
she died when I was
12 and when I discovered what the
scripture says do you know what a relief
that was actually that when I realized
the situation of the Dead it
was thank Heaven that it's like that
because you you constantly have this
notion that she's up there in heaven
chewing a fingernails
watching what you do that's that's silly
and stupid and ridiculous and dangerous
and uh seeing every sin that you are
committing I mean it must be a nightmare
to watch it all right or to see your
children struggling and going through
hard times and nobody to take care of
them some of them end up in foster homes
and
unhappy some are happy
whatever and all of that just
disappears they know nothing they are
asleep yeah God
knows but God is also the only one who
can redeem you from all the mistakes and
all of those issues so you want to
confess your sins to God and you want
want to make right with God and then you
want to trust in him but thank God that
your loved ones are unaware of all the
pitfalls that you go through and the
mistakes that you make Matthew
24: 30 tells us what will happen to the
wicked because remember there will be
dead ones they will not rise for a
thousand years and there will be living
ones and then shall appear the sign of
the son of man in heaven and then shall
all the tribes of the earth
mourn and they shall see the son of man
coming in the Clouds Of Heaven with
power and great Glory so here's a great
multitude that is not very happy they're
mourning so what happens to them
Revelation 6:15 to17 and the kings of
the earth and the great men and the rich
men and the chief captains I think
people should watch the news
to know who we're talking about exactly
right all these leaders all everything
who's part of this who's part of this
and who are these great men and who are
these rich men and who are these Chief
captains and mighty men and bondsmen and
every free man hid themselves in the
dens and in the rocks of the mountains
and said to the mountains and the Rocks
fall on us and hide us from the face of
him that sits on the throne and from the
wroth of the lamb for the great day of
his wroth is come and who shall be able
to stand Martin they still have time for
reflection yes I think some of the kings
of the world might still change sides
Nebuchadnezzar did yeah but there will
be few and far
between maybe some of the rich men will
change sides and put their energies on
God's sides rather than what they're
doing at the
moment behold the Lord come cometh with
10, thousands of his Saints that's the
angels to execute judgment upon all and
to convince all that are ungodly amongst
them of all their ungodly Deeds which
they have ungodly committed and of all
their hard speeches which ungodly
Sinners have spoken against them what in
this verse Jude 14 and
15 how many people and how many uh
programs use the lord's name in vain and
mock him to his face I think it's almost
a miracle if you find one that does not
blaspheme the name or use the name in
vain now most of the actors in this
world belong to secret fraternities
right and those secret fraternities
especially when you get to the higher
levels are luciferians mhm and they hate
Christ yeah therefore it is second
nature for them to use the lord's name
in vain and uh they use it as an
explicit in virtually every movie that's
it therefore it's impossible for me to
look at some of these things that's true
because it's horrendous the way they act
if they were to do the same with even
the prophets of some of the other
religions they could end up being
lynched Zephaniah 114 and 15 the great
day of the Lord is near it is near and
hasten this greatly even the voice of
the of the Lord the Mighty Men shall cry
there bitterly that day is a day of
wroth a day of trouble and distress a
day of
wastesson a day of clouds and thick
Darkness so there are two groups yes
yeah those that say this is our God we
have waited for him and he will save us
it's the best day ever it's wonderful
full of glory and this is the worst day
ever all right for the other for the
other
group and then shall the wicked be
revealed whom the Lord shall consume
with the spirit of his mouth and shall
destroy with the brightness of his
coming now that's a very interesting
verse so you cannot stand in the
presence of God in that brightness if
you are the man of sin if you are sinful
and you know what we've got these two
explanations of the difference of how
it's going to be for the different um
groups but the sad part is that both of
them it's their own choice it's their
choice if you cling to sin you'll be
destroyed together with it yeah so maybe
it's not the sad part it's sad and good
part is it's your own choice correct now
what comes out of the mouth of of the
Lord man shall not live by bread alone
but by every word that proceedeth of the
mouth of God correct so they will be
judged by the word yeah and by the law
of God that's it there is the standard
and Jeremiah makes it very clear 25:33
and the slain of the Lord shall be at
that day from one end of the Earth even
unto the other end of the Earth they
shall not be lamented neither gathered
nor buried they shall be dung upon the
ground so where do they come across this
idea of a temporal Millennium where
everybody body is converted yeah you're
on Earth doesn't happen it's not
biblical so in other words they cannot
be lamented and they cannot be gathered
and they cannot be buried because the
living righteous are gone and everybody
else is dead dead so they shall be dung
upon the ground that's the
reality Zephaniah tells us how complete
this destruction will be I will utterly
consume all things from all the land
says the Lord I will consume man and
Beast I will consume the fowls of the
Heaven and the fishes of the Sea and the
stumbling blocks with the wicked and I
will cut off man from off the land says
the Lord so what happens to the Animal
Kingdom also there'll be nothing left
nothing there's nothing on Earth alive
so this this earth goes back to its
primordial State the abusos yeah the the
abbis where the spirit of God went over
correct now to make quite sure Psalms
110 ver 5 and
6 the Lord at thy right hand shall
strike through kings in the day of his
wrath he shall judge amongst the Heathen
he shall fill the places with dead
bodies and he shall wound the heads over
many countries what does that tell you
about the leaders of the world in the
last days they will be destroyed with
the man of sin Martin I've been looking
at all the events at the terrible
tyranny that is taking place of all over
the world how the kings of the world are
lording it over their subjects hurting
them into camps yeah melt treating them
I've been looking at some of the
statistics at how people people are
affected by the procedures that are
being used today how many people are
dying how many children are
born uh misformed or deformed how many
children are still born babies still
born the suffering in the world is
unbelievable and like you said a lot of
it's been implemented by these Great Men
yes so I wonder whether they they know
what is coming are they doing it because
they are deceived are they doing it
because they are
convinced I think they should become
convicted and should look at what the
world is going through and ask
themselves the question are we dealing a
right with the Lord's
Heritage those that he died for Jeremiah
4 from verse 23 onwards I beheld the
Earth and lo it was without form and
void and the heavens there had no
light so this was because they rolled up
like a scroll right I beheld the
mountains and lo they trembled and all
the hills moved lightly I beheld and
there there was no
man and all the birds of Heaven were
fled so there were no birds I beheld and
lo the fruitful place was a Wilder
Wilderness and all the cities thereof
were broken down at the presence of the
Lord and by his Fierce anger for thus
says the
Lord for thus has the Lord said the
whole land shall be desolate yet will I
not make a full end for this shall the
Earth mourn and the heavens above be
black because I have spoken it I have
purposed it and I will not repent
neither will I turn back from it it so
this is what happens at the second
coming of Christ everything is destroyed
but it's not the end yet no there's
something that will take place in heaven
and then there will be a third coming of
Christ for a final com culmination of
all of these things but the Bible is
clear there will be desolate cities and
the wicked living are slain at the
second coming
in other words there can be no secret
Rapture no it's not possible not
especially if you read this Jeremiah
verse now so everything they say about
the secret
Rapture comes out of a Jesuit
teaching
dispensationalism and we've had the
progression of this teaching coming out
of the Jesuit SC stable and out of Rome
and it has infiltrated the world and the
evangelicals are not teaching a Biblical
Doctrine but a jesuitical
Doctrine we read in 2 Thessalonians 1 16
and 7 seeing it is a righteous thing
with God to recompense tribulation to
them that trouble you and to you who are
troubled rest with us when the Lord
Jesus shall be revealed from heaven with
his mighty Angels what a beautiful
verse a day of Retribution is coming and
if you want to have retribution then
choose that but if you want to have rest
with God's people well then that's a
different
Choice Revelation 20 ver1 and 2 says and
I saw an angel come down from heaven
having the keys of the bottomless pit
and a great chain in his hand and he
laid hold on the dragon that old serpent
which is the devil and Satan and bound
him a thousand years so what for a
thousand
years the devil is bound down here mhm
and he is bound in the sense that
there's nobody left to confuse or lead
astray yes everything is dead he's
sitting on a broken planet and he can
just think of him about everything so
Satan is bound in change of circumstance
for a thousand years Psalm 68 verse 6
says God Seth the solitary in families
he bringeth out those which are bound
with chains but the rebellious dwell in
a dry land now are these spiritual
change chains of circumstance or are
they literal this is circumstance
exactly so in the same way the devil is
bound by chains of
circumstance so this is what happens in
the
Millennium M anus means
1,000 years for one Thousand Years the
dead shall not be raised the wicked dead
they will not rise for a thousand years
says the Bible all the animals all the
cities everything is destroyed the
righteous have met the Lord in the air
and have been taken away and the dead
that were not in Christ are dead MH and
only the devil and his angels is bound
here by chains of
circumstance so mtin this is basically
the summary right yes now when the Bible
speaks about the battle of
Armageddon what was that battle when the
Bible speaks about the Battle of Gogan
Magog yeah what was that battle how do
we fit all of these into
scripture so basically in a nutshell the
battle of Armageddon is what takes place
when Christ returns he Wars against
those kings and against all the
impenitent and they are destroyed by the
brightness of his coming and by the
culmination of the seventh
plague but I think we should deal with
that in a little bit more detail and
just flesh it out what are these battles
that take place and uh describe
Armageddon describe what happens in the
Millennium and describes what happens at
the Battle of Gog and Magog MH mhm and
uh then we can sum it all up and have a
correct sequence or a Biblical sequence
as to what the chain of events is yes
that's so perhaps we should uh make a
part two and continue this discussion in
another one yes that would be great okay
so shall we
pray Heavenly Father
the second coming will be a very
glorious
event but it will also be a very tragic
event for probably the great majority of
humanity and it is therefore of utmost
importance that we understand the
sequence of events and that we also
understand what our part
is namely to confess our sins for
forsake our sins and claim the
righteousness of
Christ because justification by faith is
the great
passport that we
require and
sanctification is our fitness for heaven
bless us in our decisions in Jesus name
amen
amen thank you for watching this video
video to subscribe to our Channel click
here to get notifications click on the
Bell to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again